be switched off this evening at six
o'clock so not too long but there will
be cold water available in jugs outside
in the breakout area so you shouldn't go
thirsty uh there will also be plenty of
hot water for teas and coffees uh during
the course of the evening
um
if the fire alarm should sound and we
have no indication it would please leave
the meeting room by following the far
exit signs and meet on the ipswich town
football club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
i will now move to the agenda uh
apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
muller councillor gould councillor ebern
and councillor whitehead thank you
um item two are there any declarations
of interest by councillors
i see none so we'll move on to item
three
item three this is paper mc oblique 2-1
oblique 2-9 is to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 24th of february
2022 and is for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
i guess not uh could i have a proposal
for the minutes then please
council
huntingham
council matheson seconding
yes thank you
i will um we're going to do this one by
show of hands all those in favor
that's unanimous thank you very much
right we will now move to item number
four this is paper
mc
2-1 oblique 3-0 that's the chairman's
announcement and uh as you will have
seen in your papers there weren't that
many things that
we attended to but uh a particular note
i thought was the
event it's a rocket science in clayton
which was absolutely fabulous and
the guys there have done a really
fantastic job of of getting out that
building and i think
many of our youngsters are going to be
truly inspired uh as we move forward in
in the space age
so thank you for that
uh we're going to move now to item
number five this is the leaders
announcement i would like to invite
councillor morley to present her update
kathy morley
thank you chair
normally i would spend time as part of
my announcements talking about our
various achievements and activities over
the last month
as you know we are unfortunately seeing
further bird flu outbreaks
in our district
we are supporting residents to reduce
the energy bills which is so crucial
given the rising cost of living
we have published our first climate
change and biodiversity annual report
we have used external funding to plant
more trees
we have secured new external funding to
provide specialized emergency
accommodation for rough sleepers
and those at risk of homelessness
and last week we underwent our corporate
peer challenge
the peer review team had 48 meetings and
spoke to over 200 people over the three
days they were here
and we are looking forward to receiving
the report and recommendations from them
before we next meet
but i want to focus my attention this
month not on what is happening in
mid-suffolk but instead on the
atrocities happening in ukraine
what actions we are taking as a result
and the motion before us tonight
it was on the same day of our meeting
last month that russia began its
invasion of the ukraine
we all publicly expressed our support
for the people of ukraine at that
meeting
since then unfortunately the situation
in ukraine has clearly worsened
and the people of ukraine have been
dragged into all-out war
we hope that peace can be reached as
soon as possible
and that the ukraine can regain its
independence and freedom
but mid-suffolk cannot and will not sit
quietly by we will be vocal in our
continued condemnation of president
putin and we will support our friends
from the ukraine
it is heartwarming to see how many
people in this country have already
signed up to help
house and shelter those escaping the war
we do not have the figures yet but i am
sure that many of the residents of
mid-suffolk have already offered
to generously fling open their doors and
spare rooms to support the refugees
much of the details of this scheme and
more generally is still to emerge from
the government
we will though be working as the suffolk
family across mid-suffolk the county
council
other local authorities and wider public
sector to make sure we wrap support
around our residents and our ukrainian
friends
i hope you will all join me later when
we debate the motion which is item 15b
on the agenda to send a clear and
unanimous message to president putin and
to the people of ukraine
thank you chairman
um
okay
in which case we're going to move now to
item number six on the agenda this is to
receive the notification of petitions in
accordance with council procedure rules
thank you chair we have received the
following validated petition 102 valid
signatures regarding planning
application dc 21 06825
land to the south of sagan hall farm
church lane wreaking hall this petition
will be dealt with through the normal
planning processes thank you
thank you
we'll now move to item seven on the
agenda this is questions by the public
in accordance with council procedure
rules
non-received chair thank you
then we'll move to item number eight
this questions by councillors in
accordance with council procedure rules
i refer you to the question
in the table papers
and i would like to invite
counselor
ottom to ask a question
thank you chairman um
i'm scanning through this trying to find
i can remember the words exactly um
obviously
we're um
slightly
we're pleased about the
small grant the government is making to
people
of 150 pounds towards their energy bills
but those will be paid only to people
that pay their council tax by direct
debit i'd like to know what the council
will be doing
to um
help those people
that do not pay by direct debit debit
so they can receive that very small sum
towards their high energy bills thank
you
council whitehead i'm going to ask
councillor molly to respond
thank you for your question councillor
otton
i must advise you that the basic premise
behind your question is incorrect
the government will be providing the
council with
5 million one hundred and ninety nine
thousand three hundred pounds in funding
to support the payment of 150 pounds
to households in council tax band a to d
that meet the qualifying criteria
this includes not only households who
pay their council tax by direct debit
but also those households who do not
where the council holds bank details on
its council tax records we can easily
and automatically pay qualifying
households the 150 pounds
paying the 150 pounds to qualifying
households who do not pay by
direct debit is not as straightforward
and a process to do this is being
developed
the current estimate is that this is in
the region of eight and a half thousand
households
once this process is finalized a letter
will be issued to those households
outlining the process that they will
need to follow to obtain the grant
we have always encouraged all households
to pay by direct debit and any household
setting up a new direct debit before the
1st of april can and will be included
within the automatic process
and therefore be in earlier receipt of
this grant
alongside the main scheme the government
will also providing the council with 161
thousand 250 pound
discretionary funding
and the council will be developing a
discretionary policy for the
administration of this limited funding
to support vulnerable households who
fall outside of the main scheme
thank you
would you like to ask a supplementary
question um
no thank you chairman but i'm pleased to
hear
that the council will be able to support
those people
and not paying by direct debit and i
would hope that the council maybe could
extend a incentive scheme to encourage
people to do just that in the future
thank you
all right we'll now move to the question
from councillor scarf cover scarf would
you like to ask your question please
firstly chairman thank you for allowing
this as an urgent question at your
discretion um i do appreciate the
opportunity to ask this question so
thank you for allowing us to do that
my question is
what steps if any of mid-southwark
district council taking on behalf of
residents to express their
disappointment of the news that hsbc
bank are closing their stone market
branch affecting users of the bank
locally and wider than just stone market
mr would you like to respond
thank you mr chair
yeah thank you for that question uh
council scarf um the council will be
riding and i've seen the letter actually
so very shortly to hb hsbc
to advise of its disappointment about
the closure of this high street bank
and to urge the bank to reconsider this
closure
as stone market is the economic center
for many rural areas it is important
that we work with the banking sector to
ensure provision is made for local
customers in the future
can i thank the portfolio holder for his
answer my supplementary question would
be why this time are we writing to the
bank when last time nat west we didn't
councillor brewster
thank you
i must admit i don't know the answer to
that one
but
uh
this is a very challenging situation
uh and having in the fairly recent past
lost in that west bank and santander
more recently barclays bank for
so-called commercial reasons
which were exact exacerbated by online
banking
we've now been notified by hsbc that
they will be closing their operation in
stone market along with a number of
other towns
this will leave just tsp in sto market
i'm assuming that the excuse for hsbc's
closure will be the same as those banks
already closed
and unfortunately this does nothing to
support those wishing to use the bank in
person
those who don't wish to use online
banking for various reasons
and those who are elderly or disabled
and whatever reason
also including those businesses in town
so the question is
what are the next steps we are taking
at this time um
i am able to confirm again that the
letter is being sent to this bank and
i've asked for it to be done in the
strongest terms
following which if the
bank take no notice that later
that
we
and given the pressure and accessibility
problems of the post office in stone
market
i've asked that we should
research another way in stone market of
serving banking for the public
and that is being
continued right now
but i'm sorry i don't know why netwest
wasn't wasn't written too
right we are now going to move to
item number nine
so this is
paper mc oblique 2-1 oblique 3-1
new code of conduct for councillors i
would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce this paper and its
recommendations
thank you chairman i'm pleased to
introduce this report which asks the
council to adopt the new model code of
conduct as its own local code of conduct
the model code was developed by the
local government association following
the recommendations made by the
committee on standards in public life
the new code of conduct is accompanied
by a set of guidance which gives greater
clarity to councillors and complainants
about the scope of the code and also the
definition of behaviors would which
would be in breach of the code
if the council agrees to adopt this new
code it will come into effect from the
annual council meetings in may
2022 and there will be training for
councillors
on the new code before it comes into
effect the format of which is currently
being discussed by the suffolk
monitoring officers group
currently the same suffolk local code of
conduct has been adopted by all tiers of
local authorities across suffolk which
has significant benefits for those of
you that are twin or
or triple hatters even
representing different councils at
different levels
we intend to maintain this approach and
we'll be recommending the adoption of
this new code to town and parish
councils in the area with the support of
the suffolk association of local
councils
i'm very happy to answer any questions
chairman and would ask for a proposal
and seconder for the recommendation
thank you
could i have us
councillor morley
thank you chair i would be delighted to
propose this report
okay could i have a second thank you
councillor mellon
you're very happy to second chair thank
you thank you
uh are there any questions for the
monitoring officer on this paper
no
in that case is that
do we wish to counter matheson
thank you thank you chair yeah i just
looking back to the to the last time we
we were brought in a new code of conduct
etc i remember there was considerable um
difficulty with the number of parishes
that decided they didn't like it and
didn't want to adopt it and um so i'm
hoping that we'll be
um
very very
articulate in our persuasions
that it is in their interests
okie dokie
right in that case um
we'd like to
kick off the debate if if we're going to
have one who would like to kick off
i think councilman matheson by d by
default sort of did that
yeah you're very welcome
well if we're not going to have a debate
i mean of you know the the code of
conduct is one that we've obviously
looked at several times in the past and
i'm sure that every councillor in the
chamber would want to behave in in the
most appropriate and proper manner in in
their role and so i'm going to ask the
officer for governance to conduct a vote
please
this will be through my modern.gov as
usual
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors can cast their
vote thank you
can i take your vote then counselor
in favor thank
you thank you chair that vote is 29 4
and one against
and that is carried
we'll now move to item 10
which is m's paper mc oblique 2-1
oblique 3-2
community governance review
i refer you to the
appendix a that's in the table to papers
i would like to invite councillor morley
to introduce this paper and move the
recommendations therein
councilman
thank you chair
i would like to introduce this report on
commencing a community governance review
in
mid-suffolk and the associated terms of
reference
the council is required under the local
government and public involvement in
health act 2007
to periodically carry out a review of
the boundaries and governments
arrangements for the parish and town
councils and unparished within the
district
the review will start on the first of
april and will be completed by december
this year with any new arrangements
coming into force before the elections
in may 2023
if a review is to be carried out it will
be delegated to the community governance
review working group
consisting of councillors susie morley
sarah mansell penny otton and john
whitehead and report its recommendations
to the council
the electoral services team will be
supporting the community governance
review working group
and i would call for a seconder thank
you
thank you
all right we will now move to questions
uh
counselor autumn what's up
um
not actually a question chairman um just
to say um thank you
to the
officers for amending the paperwork um
the chairman of suffolk locus
salk
must have seen this far in advance of
myself and noticed that the timeline was
completely
incorrect
and obviously there were some obviously
somebody had cut and paste
so could i ask whether salk will be part
of the consultation if this goes through
please
i don't know
we've got edward mccready
all right
mr mccready would you
chair help us i'd like to report that
we'll be talking to all stakeholders and
writing to all stakeholders once this is
approved including salk mps yourselves
and your various hats
and anybody else that has an interest
that we can identify thank you very much
you're very welcome catholic autumn um
counselor mantle
uh thank you chair i i understand that
that this has been some time coming
because i know some parishes have been
asking about
certain changes to their governance
arrangements or whatever it's called
um
so i understand that this this uh
community governance review will be
clearly looking at those parishes that
have made requests for us to look at it
um and i couldn't i i
when i read the papers
i sort of assumed that it was i wanted
to ask if we would be looking at other
things as well as the one the parishes
that have requested us to look at it
that was certainly the impression i got
from the paperwork so can i just have
that clarified
[Music]
chair the intention is that this is
going to encompass all parishes and
unparished areas we'll be writing to
every parish council by the via the
clerk and all unparished areas and
parish meetings
it's going to be all encompassing
thank you for that
are there any other questions
if not then we shall move to debate and
councillors will be allowed to speak for
three minutes during the debate which
will be timed
who would like to kick off
no
councillor scarf
thank you chair
well as a member of another parish
council i'm very pleased that we're
actually finally conducting this
community governance review
our own parish stone market was one to
ask for this some years ago so it's been
delayed for a little while so very
pleased and welcomed the community
governance review and let's see what
comes out of it
make a counsellor
okay
councillor morley as we don't seem to be
getting into a big debate here can i uh
ask you if you wish to add anything
counselor molly
super in which case i'm going to ask the
corporate manager for governance and the
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors can cast their
vote thank you
chair that is 30 votes for that is
unanimous
we will move on to item number 11. this
is paper mc oblique 2-1 oblique 3-3
designation of the section 151 officer
role
i would like to invite the chief
executive to introduce this paper
thank you chairman and good evening
councillors and as councillors will be
aware the statutory officer positions
within the council for within your gift
for appointment so that's the head of
paid service the monitoring officer and
the section 151 officer as you'll see
from the report and as you're aware
already
our existing section 151 officer is
sadly retiring at the end of april and
you've passed on your thanks i think in
numerous meetings to her and i'm
grateful for you for doing so and by all
means do so again if you wish as she's
here tonight it's always good to
embarrass her
but as a result of her retirement as you
would expect we've been out to
recruitment to replace uh both for her
substantive role as assistant director
for corporate resources and therefore
equally to deal with the issue of the
appointment of a section 151 officer
so in terms of the recruitment of the
assistant director again you'll see
within the report we've been through a
lengthy exercise utilizing external
support through penner executive
recruitment
they put candidates having gone through
a recruitment exercise put candidates
through a number of hoops
from recording videos of themselves to a
technical interview to an interview with
a stakeholder group of external officers
and support from other organizations
through an ex through an interview with
yourselves or some of yourselves in
terms of a stakeholder panel made up of
councillors
and then a final interview as well as
being grilled by the senior leadership
team as well um you'll see and you will
have seen through working together i'm
sure a few weeks ago that as a result of
that melissa evans who you will all be
familiar with has been appointed to the
role of assistant director for corporate
resources and so this report this
evening is simply asking you to equally
appoint her as your formerly as your
section 151 officer
councillor molly and now could i have a
second uh countley flatman okay
so uh
before i move on to the next bit i think
i want to lead the chorus of people who
would love to embarrass you uh
catherine steele because
in my time on the council i i can
honestly say that you've always been
extremely clear and forthright in giving
us good advice
and it's the sort of advice that's
allowed this council to have a really
strong financial position
uh and and give us the strength to do
the things that we're looking to do over
the next few years so
um i thank you on behalf of the council
on behalf of myself and i wish you well
in your retirement and i'm sure that in
melissa evans we have a fantastic and
very capable ass
replacement so thank you both
[Applause]
uh right does anyone have any questions
at all or anything to say on this
right in which case i'm going to ask the
corporate manager for governance and
oh councillor molly i beg your pardon
i'm too excited
i
i don't have a question but following in
your footsteps chair
i was part of the interview panel for
melissa evans
and we did have two strong candidates
come forward for interview
but melissa's energy and enthusiasm and
passion for mid-suffolk i really shone
through
and so i really want to congratulate you
melissa you did a really good interview
and i'm really looking forward to
working with you even more than we have
before so thank you very much
[Applause]
right
thank you councillor morley now i will
definitely ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue council is for you to cast your
vote thank you
chair that is 30 votes for unanimous
right
we're going to move to item 12 and
before we engage with this particular
item i'd like to ask members of the
senior leadership team to please some
remove themselves from the chamber while
we discuss it and
then we can proceed
of course that's with the exception of
the chief executive officer who's
actually
going to present the report and
the current section 5151 officer
um i would also like to draw
counsellor's attention to the fact that
uh we have with us this evening steve
davies
uh who's the employer services
specialist from london councils and i
would like to welcome him to the meeting
mr davis if you make yourself known
thank you very much
okay so now i will now ask the chief
executive to introduce paper mc
21 34 and its recommendations chief
executive
thank you chairman and good evening
again councillors um so this report
comes before you tonight having
previously
come forward in a different incarnation
back last september that you may recall
at the time that that report was
withdrawn from you so you didn't get the
opportunity to debate it at the time and
the reason being that on that occasion
baby's full council meeting happened
before your full council meeting and it
was rejected at the bay before council
meeting and therefore logically
withdrawn at that stage
i should say at this point not least
because the chairman mentioned the fact
that i'm still in the room the change
one of the changes since last time
around as you may remember that the
report contained details in relation to
my pay and proposals in relation to my
pay at my request the leader has
withdrawn that remove those elements uh
which is what means i can comfortably
stand here before you tonight and both
present the report and answer any
questions if you have any uh for us uh
similarly uh on the last occasion
catherine steele would have had to have
withdrawn but given that imminently as
we've said already she will be retiring
so she's comfortable to stay with us we
also have suzanne hughes who's our head
of hr and od if there are any specific
hrod questions alongside steve davies so
the report before you tonight deals with
the pay policy statement but more
particularly is designed to make some
changes in relation to the pay
arrangements for the senior officers uh
you'll appreciate and you will all be
aware that following the withdrawal of
the report last time round rounds there
have been lots of meetings since in your
group meetings and similarly with baby
colleagues in the same vein
what that yielded was at least 23
different concerns points issues that i
know councillors wanted us to address in
making changes to the report as it was
drafted back in september and actually
that 23 got expanded because once you
were having discussions it went beyond
23 i think that last count it was
something like 26 or or 27.
all of those points have been addressed
picked up and incorporated both within
the covering report that you have before
you tonight but also within a part of
the ilga report and just to explain
steve's presence unfortunately michelle
kirk who wrote the actual report on
behalf of the east of england lga
suffered a bereavement and so she can't
be with us tonight so steve's very
kindly stepped in as you heard from the
london employer's side but he's very
familiar with this type of work
so the recommendations that you've got
before you i think that'd be useful for
me just to briefly outline them i know
councillors have seen them before but
just for completeness completely as if i
outlined them for you this evening and
then i'm more than happy to take any
questions uh once the
report has been proposed and seconded so
in terms of the recommendations 3.1 and
3.2 are the key elements in relation to
salary they are the ones that make the
changes to the directors levels of
salaries and you'll recall from the
report director level salaries their
base salaries haven't been reviewed for
over 11 years
and they're now being looked at in terms
of this report
recommendation 3.3 then asks me to look
again at the question of job titles so
i've broadly just referred to them as
directors just to get me out of the
whole of being specific in terms of this
report but i'm more than happy to go
away and look at job titles again to
bring them in line with modern
terminology and what other councils are
using
that's recommendation 3.4 assuming that
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 uh approved
would create the headroom financially
for me to be able to then do the
complete review of all staff in relation
to pay that's the reason why it's coming
forward in this order
that i don't need your permission for
that's within my gift but i do need the
the headroom in order to be able to
progress with that the financial
headroom to be able to progress with
that and i know councillors were keen to
see that formerly confirmed within the
report that i would do that and that i
would do that within a certain time
scale and so that's encompassed within
3.4
at 3.5 is to pick up the point that
under the current arrangements and this
is true of all officers not just senior
officers
the increments so the five increments
that you'll see under recommendations
3.1 and 3.2 and similarly for all other
staff they are achieved essentially on
an annual basis by virtue of having been
at the authority for another year as
long as performance is not poor
in effect you can hear from my words
that it's not therefore performance
related pay i.e you don't have to be
performing well to receive your
increment you just have to not be
performing poorly i think there's a
problem with that and i know councillors
have expressed that concern as well
whilst not wishing to implement a full
performance related pay type arrangement
like you might see in the private sector
but a greater alignment between pay and
performance and so that's what that
recommendation is saying that i would go
away and do
3.6
is then simply adopting i say simply but
adopting the pay policy statement you're
obliged by law to adopt a pay policy
statement every year and so that's the
formal act in this report of doing so
and then 3.7 is notwithstanding the fact
that you look at the pay policy
statement on an annual basis is
recognizing that time has gone away from
us and that's part of the reason why we
found ourselves with the need to address
this in such a significant way because
as i said at the start that pay at this
level hasn't been reviewed for over 10
years and so 3.7 that recommendation is
ensuring that we don't get back into
that problem again by making sure that
there is a detailed review in relation
to pay at least every four years the
idea being that you don't therefore find
a position where you get too far behind
the market as we find it today
so hopefully that's all self-explanatory
i know councils have had discussions
around this in group meetings beforehand
so i'm more than familiar with it and
probably didn't leave me to do that
explanation but i think it's important
for the public to hear that
as well if there are any questions more
than happy to answer them otherwise i
will sit down and hopefully somebody
will propose and second the motions
thank you arthur um i have a proposal
please counselor morley
thank you and councillor mellon to
second thank you very much indeed okay
so we'll now move to questions
counselors will be allowed
up to three questions doesn't mean you
should ask three questions but you're
allowed up to three questions and they
must be relevant to the matter under
discussion and please
questions should be questions who would
like to ask the first question
counselor matheson remember you're
asking a question yes yes
yes recommendation 3.3 i was quite
puzzled by this actually because it
doesn't actually seem that long ago that
we were told that it would be it would
be beneficial
to recruitment etc to call the heads of
service assistant directors instead so i
was rather wondering what um what more
modern titles had overtaken that
thank you chairman
i appreciate that it didn't seem that
long ago but it was certainly before my
time so it was well over five years ago
so i'm not entirely sure when it was but
nonetheless you're absolutely right
that's one of the challenges that there
aren't that many job titles to play
around with in that respect and equally
i will express a personal view that i
really don't care what officers are
called uh and that's not the important
thing but what is important is that
their job titles properly reflect what
they do and aren't dare i say local
government mumbo jumbo in terms of
making it difficult for the public and
difficult for councillors and dare i
said difficult for fellow officers to
absolutely understand well what exactly
is that job that the key thing more
often than not is to make sure that the
job title gets that relevant officer the
foot in the door of other organizations
and sans say that it is the fact still
that unless you've got the right job
title sometimes that's harder to do and
i suspect that may well be council
madison why the argument was for moving
from heads of service to assistant
directors sometime some time ago now so
i don't have a pre uh preconceived view
as to what the new job title should be
it is something that i looked at loosely
about 12 months ago and left it alone
but as i said it was something the
council has raised and as a result i'm
more than happy to look at it again
are there any other questions
okay if there are no further questions
then we shall move to debate and
councils will be allowed to speak for
three minutes and this will be timed so
who would like to kick off the debate
councilor mello
yeah thank you chair
clearly this is a tricky ish issue and
there's some some history behind it
but i'm glad we've got to this point now
where i think we can
um there's likely to be
a majority to accept this this
recommendation today
um
[Music]
myself i don't feel qualified to assess
what level of pay
um you know senior um
officers should be receiving um and
that's why we we go out to to to
consultants and and people who know
better and who can um look across a
range of councils and get a get an idea
of whether we're behind or ahead um and
it seems you know from from that um
information we've been given that we are
a little bit behind the the going rate
and that explains why we have struggled
to
recruit to some of these roles
so i think we um it's an uncomfortable
situation but but we have to be
realistic and we have to accept the
situation we're in we've fallen behind
um
for me um the comfort of knowing that
there's going to be a review of all the
staff
in in the organization
over the next year and having a sort of
fixed date for that that does give me
some level of comfort about this
decision i don't want the senior staff
to be you know moving ahead and everyone
else to be left behind so
i'm happy to second this and i'll be
voting for it thank you chair
councilor richardson
thank you very much uh chair just a few
uh brief comments from me if i may uh
i'll be supporting this uh
wholeheartedly i think this is as as
many have mentioned already long overdue
and i think in particular it goes some
way to address some of the key
organizational challenges that we have
the first as council mellon quite
rightly said is the question of
recruitment and retention and i think
that's a really important point to
reflect on because if we you know as an
organization we do have significant
aspirations and it's incumbent on us as
a council to ensure we have the resource
and the right level of expertise to
deliver um that ambition and i think
it's absolutely right that we then
address this given enormous amount of
time it's been since the these salaries
were last reviewed um and i think as a
report makes clear it's important we are
moving in line uh with other comparative
local government uh councils to ensure
that we are competitive um and i think
it's also worth reflecting on the
alternative is to rely on interim
appointments if we can't recruit which
will just ultimately end up becoming
more expensive for us as an organization
and then again just again completely as
councilman said i think the other aspect
of this is then unlocking that future
review of um the pay of all of our staff
because
ultimately when we and again that's not
from a recruitment and retention
perspective but also let's think about
this from a well-being perspective we
talk about the world being of our
residents i certainly do um but actually
we also have a duty of care and
responsibility to our own staff we've
talked at this meeting in the last about
the inflationary pressures that our
residents are facing that that same
applies to officers and i think if we're
going to progress this then that enables
us to look at
the pay of staff across across our
organization which i think is
fundamentally the right thing to do in
general but particularly at the present
so i think this is a really important
report and i thank those involved and
will certainly be supporting and voting
in favor thank you jeff
councillor richardson councilor morley
thank you chair
just in case you any doubt given that i
proposed it i am voting for this
um
when i first joined the council in 2015
a goodly number of our senior leadership
team were interims
and it's a bit of an
anachronism in our system
that interims
can be appointed willy-nilly
at vast cost without the approval of
council
whereas to employ
somebody on a full-time basis or even on
a part-time basis at this level
does require um council to get involved
in the setting of the pay scales so for
me
this an is a bit of an anachronism that
needs to be
got rid of when arthur joined
uh mid-suffolk and paper
the first thing we said to him
was that he had to get rid of all the
interims and he's done this
and it's been
hard work
to
restructure we've had restructures
we need to pay our staff
something that is commensurate with what
they can get in our
other local organizations around suffolk
and at the moment
a corporate manager can leave here and
go and work
as a director for another council and be
earning more
than our directors do and that is simply
not fair we we take great pains to grow
our own offices
melissa is a fine example
of that
and we need to be able to pay them a
commensurate salary
in order to keep them for as long as we
can we invest a lot of time in there
in their training as well as their
well-being
and i want to keep our staff our staff
are fantastic
and we we need to keep them when we need
to pay them properly in order to do so
thank you councillor morning
go for field
thank you
always a difficult subject to discuss
i guess my feeling is that
a situation where has a large number of
interim staff is is somewhat ridiculous
it's extremely expensive
and it's disruptive to other people as
well
it implies that you don't value the
permanent people you value the interims
but there's always a difficulty with
with
with vacancies why can't we recruit to
opposition
and there's always two possibilities
that the people you're trying to attract
don't fancy the environment it doesn't
have ambition or what they don't like
the people they'd be working with or the
reputation of the people they're working
with is poor
or the salary is too low to attract
movement
i find it difficult to believe that
either of the first two things i
mentioned are true in this environment
uh
the council does have her ambition
and i'm sure that uh
the surrounding staff will be more than
acceptable to any recruit so it has to
be that it's a salary issue and there
was some evidence generated to support
that as councilman morley's just
mentioned
so i find that
given that we are intending to
review the salaries of other staff
members as well
further down the in the hierarchy
i'm fairly comfortable that this is the
right thing to do the salary levels
proposed are appropriate
perhaps with just one other caveat one
the chief exec made about
progression from stage to stage not
being merely because you've managed to
drive here for another year
but that you actually have contributed
to the
development of the organization at the
level appropriate to this sort of staff
so
i feel that it must be fairly obvious
that i will be voting to support this
thank you
councillor
doesn't appear to be working
shall i shout no you're you're looking
at you're talking to the wrong machine
right
okay
well i'm not going to say very much
anyway
but hopefully but hopefully it'll be
worthwhile me saying it yeah it it is
very important to be able to recruit
quality staff
levels below corporate
manager those who aspire to move up the
hierarchy so i'm pleased that there will
be an across-the-board review
and expect it to be completed by the
31st of march 2023 as it states in the
recommendation
and i hope it will be implemented from
the first of april 2023 and not
not delayed so i will be supporting the
recommendation
thank you councillor willem uh
councillor passmore thank you very much
chairman just a couple of comments i
agree with what has been said but i'd
also i mean i shall be supporting this
just to people reflect if you go back a
long long time ago 15 20 years that some
of us can remember where of course you
had baber and mid-suffolk's two discreet
organizations
it was rationalized and i forget the um
some of the top salaries there but that
was effectively not quite half but
certainly recognized that so there's
been a big productivity growth um which
we need to recognize and of course
recently
now we are trying to operate as
two sovereign councils but all under one
roof so to speak without getting into a
tangled up debate on that
also bear in mind the different
constraints and requirements on local
authorities and the population growth
that we have both um down in baby and
mid-suffolk so
um
yes we do need to look at taxpayers
value for money but we do need the right
staff and the incentivization of them to
make sure they have real focus
on delivery to the benefit of our local
council taxpayers and i'm sure arthur
has got that completely under both wings
and will no doubt be working very hard
continue to working hard to make sure
that's delivered so i shall certainly
support it thank you
thank you past more uh councillor
stringer
uh thank you chair uh
i'll be fairly brief uh
just want to make the point that all of
local government is struggling to
recruit at the moment even those that
are paying the most
so
i will be supporting the recommendation
and i'm really glad that it's going to
start a review of all staff which was
that was i have to say a sticking point
for me and now we've got that into the
recommendation i'm very grateful thank
you
but just don't be aware this isn't a
magic bullet just by
uh giving a commensurate salary with
others will not save and and and our
recruiting problems all at once
what will help is you know the culture
of the authority and and the schemes
that we bring about and the good works
that we do
that that will help encourage new people
in and equally
while we're talking about retaining our
existing staff please don't forget that
we have lost staff here that have gone
to other councils for a pay cut
so this isn't a magic bullet but i will
be supporting the recommendation thank
you chair
stringer
okay
well um
i guess that um
you know the the comments that have been
made uh across the chamber can reflect
the feeling that we as a council want to
make sure that we have
the best possible team batting on our
behalf and on behalf of our
uh citizens and
and and making sure that you know we
deliver on the
the important priorities that we've set
this council and and we do that with um
expertise uh skill
and
no less com compassion i think one of
the things i would like to also see is
that there's a very clear
understanding for staff below the
director level as to what the
opportunities are for them to progress
within the organization because i think
that says a lot about the strength of
our organization if people can see that
there are roots of progression through
the ranks
so i do welcome the pay policy i do
think that we're off in the right
direction and i thank councillors for
their contributions this evening and um
before we move to the vote i guess i
would like to ask the chief executive if
you'd like to say anything else
that's the right answer arthur thank you
very much
okay i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for councillors to cast their
vote
um thank you chair that is
30 in favor
so that is unanimous again
and mr davis thank you for being here
even if we didn't call upon you but we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us
for the other officers to return so we
can move to item number 13.
um we're moving now to item 13 mc21
oblique 3-5
decisions taken by the chief executive
under delegated pass in accordance with
part two of the constitution i would
like to invite the monitoring officer to
introduce this paper please and it it's
just for noting
thank you chairman
the council is asked to note the
schedule of decisions taken by the chief
executive under delegated authority
the first two decisions relate to urgent
decisions that were required um to
respond to the increase in the omicron
variant of the covid virus earlier this
year
and the final two relate to the making
of neighbourhood plans in needham
markets and thorndon following a
successful referendum result thank you
thank you
so that was for noting and we'll now
move to item number 14
councillor appointments
chair i haven't received any but i don't
know if there's any on the evening
council no councilmember okay
so uh
before i'm going to call a break at this
juncture because it's got really warm in
here
so if we could take 10 10 minutes out
and cool down hopefully the temperature
will have dropped a little bit by the
time we come back and then we can
proceed with item 15. thank you
right i i hope you were able to get a
little bit of respect
doesn't seem like the room's any cooler
but let's let's press on uh so we're now
at item 15 motions on notice
and the first motion a is to consider
the motion on notice received from
councillor morley so cousin molly
oops
if you
like to move your motion
thank you chair this motion
the council supports the petition
launched by adso and llg on the 5th of
january with regard to remote and hybrid
meetings
we agreed to write to the secretary of
state for leveling up housing and
communities
calling on the government to change the
law to allow councils the flexibility
to hold such meetings when they deem
appropriate
within agreed rules and procedures
i've attached the model motion
and i'll call for a second i thank you
yeah thank you chip um
i'm very grateful to castle morley for
proposing this motion and
and also for asking me to to second it
which i'm happy to do
um is okay if i speak now is that right
yes
um members will remember i'm sure the
start of the covert pandemic almost two
years ago
and the shock of that first
lockdown and the prime minister
announcing on television we all had to
stay at home in the house and once it
became clear this is going to be for a
considerable time we all had to work out
how we could connect online how we could
somehow
continue the work of the council um
and and our role in it as councillors
um
and i want to pay tribute to councillor
carter here because
he was a bit ahead of the game because
probably six months before that he'd
said to us as a group oh we really
should be meeting remotely we should be
using zoom we should be using teams and
some other thing i've never heard of
these things before but he was he was
ahead of the curve
and then of course we all had to learn
how to use them we had to learn how to
use zoom and
you know i'd only done a couple of skype
calls before that but you know we
we've learned how to use these tools and
we've managed to
for a little while when the law allowed
we were able to do the work of the
council online
so we had you know
development control meetings we had full
council meetings on teams
for sure it wasn't perfect
you know i think the phrase of
2020 was you're still on mute
um and we all we've all made that
mistake
but i think it was better than not
meeting
and still we were able to continue the
work of the council
and it's a shame that the government
hasn't stepped up and
and made that change permanent so that
we have that option of
having a hybrid meeting or having a
remote meeting when circumstances allow
so just a couple of points just to
finish off the government called for
evidence on this issue last march march
uh
i know there's been a change in the
secretary of state in that department
since then but we do need them to get on
with it and i think this motion you know
does give them a little bit of a push
from us and for lots of other councils
too
there are benefits from from from going
online or from having hybrid meetings
their savings in cost there's less
travel
and it's often easier for councils to to
access
several meetings i remember you know one
evening
when i went to three different parish
councils you know sitting in in my
office
which much much less easy to do in in
real life
there are problems as well i mean it's
less easy to catch the kind of
non-verbal cues the body language the
tone
it's difficult to read the room when
you're in a team's meeting
okay last point
this motion isn't isn't asking for an
imposition of this we have a choice but
we do need that change in the law so i
welcome this motion and i encourage
colleagues to support it thank you chair
thank you councillor mellon
we will now move to debate uh
councillors will be allowed to speak for
three minutes and just once and this
will be timed
so who would like to kick off the debate
counselor matheson the floor is yours
i i welcome this certainly i have to say
um
i signed a petition um to this effect 12
months ago that the um
society of local government lawyers or
somebody like that was was actually
proposed
promoting and and the reason the reason
we need it
um is reflected that when
we started having um virtual meetings
the the attendance by parish councillors
and objectors um improved at the
planning committee meetings
which was welcome and and then it
dropped off again when the
um
when the emergency legislation was not
renewed and and that was very
disappointing as as council mellon has
said so i hope that the government
listens to the many many councils and
others that are asking for this
option option to be available and then
we'll see more parish parishes
represented here at the planning
committee again
uh thank you councillor matheson
anyone else like councillor field
yes there's a brief point or two to add
i i guess as someone who used video
conferencing um
in the late 1990s at bt quite heavily i
i would logically support its
introduction 20 years later to
local government i certainly think
everything that's been said about the
efficiency it gains in some
circumstances is absolutely true
it's something that we should press
government to get on with and authorise
i think there are some issues
the one i immediately thought of is the
thought of
people who can log on to a meeting
turn their picture and their sound off
and then go do something else until they
know it's time to vote
and when they have not listened to the
rest of the debate and clearly in some
meetings like say planning meetings it's
you to consider it essential that you
listen to what's going on so there are
some issues that we need to address but
it'd be totally wrong to
prevent uh
prevent us moving forward in
into this century
um because there are differences there
are difficulties with everything we
choose to do so i certainly will be
supporting this
thank you council
council guthrie
[Music]
thank you chair um i would just like to
reiterate what's been said i was the
first person to hold the planning
meeting and i would like to thank
everybody from the offices
and the opposition although we don't use
that in planning we were all together
and we had fabulous training
between us all and we all sort of really
put our backs into it and at the end of
it although my knees were knocking we
all patted ourselves on the back it
really was an excellent performance and
so i think it's very well worthwhile to
consider and i would be happy to do it
again thank you very much thank you
councilman
councillor carter
thank you
um i do recognize but there are benefits
to meeting in person for vienna to read
accused
there are
some emotional benefits as well being we
are social animals looking at screens
not always beneficial
however
i do believe given the option it far
over benefits far outweigh any negatives
there may be
it's a from an accessible point of view
we could have councillors
who wouldn't the people who would not
stand for elections
due to health
not being able to leave a room not be
able to attend meetings
so having be able to open up an
accessibility
to those who may not have a voice
currently or may not feel they have a
voice
far outweighs any negativity in my
opinion
there's also the benefits of
cutting down fuel
fuel consumption not having to travel
officers who may have to travel to many
different meetings in a day
so
would be able to attend meetings
without well from the armchair as it
were
and not only that we um
you could have um
not only that you'd have a pause button
if you get your loan of speech
um
no
but um
i'd say be a positive positive as far
away for negatives for this
and it's not an option that we should
certainly consider thank you
from manson
uh thank you chair um i'm backing the
trend here because i will not be
supporting this motion don't get me
wrong i'm very much in favor of using
the technology to support meetings and
we are not talking here about allowing
officers to present remotely or parish
councils to make representations
remotely that does not need a petition
to the government i believe that's
already illegally allowed and we just
need to get the technology and the
licensing in place for it to be
happening we are talking here about
members meetings and we're not all
fortunate enough to have a private space
at home where we can fully engage with
online meetings
it's so much harder to concentrate
on the matters of the meeting when
you're surrounded by domestic chaos at
home
okay maybe you're not as chaotic as i do
but um and i also share counselor
field's comments about how will actual
members attendance
throughout the duration of the meeting
be monitored if we were to have such
meetings
virtual platforms i don't think are
suited to large meetings where we need
to debate they do not promote open um
and for fair debate and discussions we
all rely on those non-verbal clues and
body language which will not be
available if we have online meetings
okay it was acceptable when we had no
alternative but now we are not so
restricted
i do not want
this to you know i i don't want to go
back to it i have my doubts about the
statement about um it being beneficial
to our work-life balance
some members um
uh who have commented that the
councillors who may be absent today due
to ill ill health would have been able
to join in with this meeting tonight but
should we really be expecting our sick
colleagues to be have to have the
possibility of being pressured into
attend if they don't feel up to it
i also have yet to be supplied with
sufficient data and evidence about the
energy consumption and carbon footprint
of the large data centers that are
required to support virtual and video
conferencing facilities until i receive
such data
that to make a really good comparison
i'm not convinced that it is less
harmful to our environment than my
current means of traveling to and from
council meetings
uh in this letter that you're proposing
that councils are allowed to have an
option of holding hybrid or virtual
meetings but who exactly will be making
the decision about the format of any
particular meeting will it be a council
decision a cabinet decision the leader
on our own the chief executive on his
own will we as the other 50 of the
council have any say in whether the
meeting is a hybrid meeting a virtual
meeting an in-person meeting um
uh so
i i have i i worry that it may end up
being a political statement thank you
councillor humphreys
mr thank you um on councillor mansell's
point it's quite interesting about the
carbon footprint about the use of data
and everything else yet everybody here
has got computer on or connected to the
internet guess what it's exactly the
same there's no difference
your point actually on the petrol and
the environment is very valid but also
is the price of fuel
imagine that not everybody is wealthy
here everybody has to travel the cost of
fuelling traveling to meetings now it's
extortionate so let's think about that
as well i know that members can claim
and perhaps the officers can and the
staff but there's a cost to it there's
an environmental cost as well if we're
living in the modern world be modern and
if you're not modern go back to the cave
simple as that
and councillor past morn thank you very
much uh paul i just want to reiterate
the issue here this motion's about
flexibility it's not about doing
everything online and so on so i think
common sense should prevail here and i
think having the flexibility i don't
believe that any chairman or chief
executive is going to impose it unless
people are generally supportive
it does clearly save on the carbon
footprint i mean for example um the
journey for me to come down here and it
was particularly just for this meeting
that's what 36 7 miles round trip
lavinia right up almost in norfolk i
don't know that's probably 50 miles or
more round trip
then there's the time factor involved as
well where you can't be productive as
you would perhaps like to be so i think
we should support this motion because it
gives the opportunity flexibility there
will be a balance i don't have a problem
for example if we have the budget debate
to come in here and do it face to face i
get the issue there
really really important things there
having that face-to-face meeting
is actually a good thing to do but have
that flexibility for heaven's sake we
need to develop and look at the costs
the debate and etc so i should be
supporting this and please remember as i
say it's the flexibility not every
single meeting um being done um remotely
and if it does allow other people who
can't get here for some reason i'm not
saying impose it on sick colleagues but
those who might just be having to
self-isolate and there's nothing else to
matter with them we'll assure you that's
more democratic
thank you thank you councilman
councillor scarf
thank you chair yeah i will be
supporting this motion
but just one point
we are sitting here with our laptops but
the main reason that we're sitting here
with our laptops is that we need to
access modern.gov.app
there is a system where we wouldn't have
to do that if we use the county council
system where it just comes up on your
microphone
for against an abstain so there are
methods that could be used that actually
reduce the carbon footprint that we're
not able to utilise because we've made
the decision to use modern.gov
tonight it's performing reasonably well
there have been a number of hitches with
members uh getting access to the vote uh
but we have had so many problems with
that over the over the course of the
time so just just be aware you know that
we could actually do even more to save
thank you councillor scarf councillor
geek
thank you chair um i have to say i'm
also worried about this motion because
of the detail of the wording as
counselor mansell says who is the they
that makes the decision
in the past the letter of council
procedure the letter rather than the
spirit has been used for political gain
examples might include using the chairs
casting vote over and over again when 50
of the council is opposition but despite
this very real worry that is based on
current behavior and practice i feel the
flexibility and the inclusivity offered
by hybrid or virtual meetings is
essential it's a pity that um that the
the emotion has been worded in this
ambiguous way
but despite my misgivings as to how that
power might be misused hope is
triumphing over experience so i'm
planning to vote for it
thank you councillor geek
councillor stringer
thank you chair i wasn't planning to
speak on this item but i fear i might
as far as i'm aware there's there's
nobody in this room that lives in the
cave
uh but occasionally uh
i did go to zoo meetings and teams
meetings in what felt like a cupboard
and it almost felt like i was a year and
a half in it
uh
having said that it was essential at
that time to for us to do any business
at all
so
uh and there were some benefits to it
i i saw body parts of fellow councillors
that i've never seen before
and i was also able to be i managed to
get two parish councils aligned so that
my council report came at the same
minute at both councils so i appear on
two sets of minutes being in two
different places at the same time which
is a first which which teams allowed me
to do
it also
if you were to look at one of the
planning meetings when i was speaking on
the microphone my son's dog chased in a
feral peacock at one point we
which
nobody wanted to hear the language that
was that was around at that time so
there's there's benefits there's also
pitfalls
i would like confirmed by the monitoring
of the chief executive though whether we
need to ask government
uh whether we can have hybrid meetings
because uh i would like a little bit
more explanation of that because frankly
for me one big pluses could be that
parish council representatives could
come in virtually if they chose
but if they then chose to
pay the car park or the train fee and
sit around for hours and hours waiting
to give their three minutes
that's completely up to them but i think
it might benefit the inclusivity of some
of our parishes and those that wish to
support or object to planning
applications for instance it might be a
very good thing so that little bit i
will be supporting it but yet again like
the thing about staff financing i don't
think it's a magic bullet thank you
thank you councillor stringer councillor
amarosa
thank you chair um so it's been raised
the issue about the wording of the uh
motion and i wonder if you could all
benefit from a bit more clarity around
that
so
uh one suggestion would be that we just
make it a blanket statement that all
meetings could be hybrid
and it's based on
on
um
members discretion or
attendees discretion
uh or i'm hoping to you know would
counsellor geek who raised the issue
have an
appropriate amendment to make
towards that end
amendment can be taken so
oh he could still make it okay no
well it depends whether the proposal of
the motion would accept it or not i
guess
have you finished i think so yeah i
haven't got a great amendment to mind
but i just if there's that question
about clarity if people agree then
yeah i probably should
think about it
um okay i'll take some advice from the
monitoring officer please
thank you chair um i think it might be
worth just clarifying that this motion
is a
intention so it's writing to the
secretary of state to say that there
should be legislative change
to make amendments to allow hybrid
meetings in their truest sense and by
that we mean allowing uh voting
councillors to attend virtually as well
as in person
and what council of stringer was
alluding to was allowing speak and other
councils actually this evening were
alluding to was allowing speakers and
other participants to join the meeting
in a virtual manner and we are
90 of the way there
in um enabling that and actually we're
looking to have our first trial of that
at the cabinet meeting uh on the 4th of
april and that will mean that
anybody who isn't who is not a voting
member of the council
or the committee meeting or a governance
officer or a legal officer can join
remotely so if we're talking about a
planning context parish councils agents
applicants any other public speakers
could join remotely and also officers
who are presenting to the committee
could join remotely so i do appreciate
your level of detail that you want to go
into because actually i want to go into
that detail too because i'll be the
person who needs to write the procedure
rules to support virtual and hybrid
meetings
but at this stage i think it's a
principal decision and if the government
was minded to pass that legislation at
that point we could go into the detail
of the mechanics of how it would work
for this council
thank you chair
indeed
um
so
councilman molly would have anything to
add
yes please
thank you
back on the
23rd of march 2020 who can forget that
it was
we were in here
being sent into lockdown and the
following day
we were all online
discussing debating
talking to each other
online through teams
our teams worked fantastically to
achieve that that was a real milestone
we were online as a council long before
most other councils
long before
and this is not just about
saying
this council we're all going to re meet
remotely
next month or whenever this is about
allowing us to have
hybrid meetings when we so decide who
here thinks that this council would not
be a better place would be a better
place if councillor eben muller
whitehead
and councillor gould were amongst us
okay
it's not about forcing people to
attend remotely especially if they're
not well
but
in pursuit of our own health and
well-being
we are asking people to stay at home
if they test positive if they've got a
slight sniffle if they've got a sore
throat to protect the rest of us
and this allows us to do just that
so
for me this is a no-brainer we need to
allow
everybody in this council to be able to
access
and hold our meetings as and when we
want in the manner in which we want
without being dictated to by central
government
so that that's my case for this and i
look forward to all your support thank
you
thank you councillor morley um i will
now ask the corporate manager governance
and civic office to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you thank you chair that vote is
now showing in blue for councillors to
cast their vote thank you
chair that is 27 4 and 2 against
married
thank you very much we will now move to
item 15b and this is to consider the
motion on notice received from
councillor morley
councillor molly would you please move
your motion
i seem to be on my feet a lot more today
than i am normally
um
so mid-south district council
we're immensely troubled by the horrific
devastation in ukraine and the
escalating humanitarian crisis facing
the country in light of this and as a
way of expressing support for members of
our communities who are from or who have
ties with ukraine this council
condemns the unprovoked russian invasion
of ukraine and stands in solidarity
with the people of ukraine and their
families and friends including those
locally to suffolk
we stand ready to provide support to
those affected by this war and will open
our arms to people displaced and
affected
we will work with and support the
efforts of our local communities to
provide and help
and comfort
to those in need
thank you chair and i'll call for a
second
thank you do you wish to speak now or
reserve your right to speak later
okay thank you very much
right um
where are we
so uh we will now move to debate on on
this motion uh who would like to start
counselor pass more
um thank you very much chairman this is
a i'm fully supportive of this motion
regarding the
heart rending and i would personally
find it almost while i do find it
traumatic the pictures and what we have
seen in the ukraine i never ever thought
in my lifetime
after the devastation we all read about
and heard about at school of world war
ii it will be turned full circle and
once again you're getting back to a
dictator a despot mad butcher of moscow
whatever we like to call them it's
despicable i also want to say at this
stage i am certainly not labeling every
person of russian descent in that same
category we need to be very clear about
that i do not believe that is the
vast majority of thought in moscow the
trouble is of course as we all know
they've been conditioned to thinking
they don't have the benefit of free
press free debate like we can have here
and throughout the u-kingdom united
kingdom much of the western world um i
think there are things that we can and
should be doing certainly from a
policing perspective i said straight
away for our procurement chain make sure
everything is taken out of there's got
anything to do with the russian economy
at all as far as you possibly can
we are all well aware of course that
it's causing huge problems for farming
like the
reserves of potash natural gas of course
clearly for ammonium nitrate but we've
learned lessons over here i think food
security we've been too complacent
defense clearly very complacent some
have said that for years it's not good
enough and energy security governments
have a moral obligation to actually plan
ahead and balance up the risk and
everything else
that we see
personally i've been in touch with the
suffolk refugees society will certainly
do what we can to welcome
those poor people from the
ukraine and i hope they can be here for
as short a time as possible before they
go back to their homeland it is such a
disgrace and i think the other thing
we've got to do is make sure we try and
arrange i suppose a boycott
um in procurement
our goods and services that we purchase
those firms that have still not pulled
out of russia there are some motor
manufacturers i believe and i do stand
to be corrected the vw group was not
pulled out but jaguar land rover bmw
volvo ford and others have pulled out
nissan and whatever the organization has
called
clearly bp and shell have been good
examples of pulling out as is exxon
i'm not so sure about french total final
elf or whatever it's called
and i was also very disappointed at the
un
that countries like bangladesh india and
others actually abstained and of course
china who i do regard as being
duplicitous in this that's a personal
view
and the last point i'd like to make mr
chairman commit and we've done this
again in policing looking at our
treasury management please can we make
sure we don't have funds put anywhere
near organizations like deutsche bank
who have also refused to pull out of
russia we've got to do everything we can
to support these poor people in the
ukraine and we must not allow this
barbaric dictator to have his way
because
once he's got that where will he be next
good luck to the ukrainian people and
we'll do everything we can to support it
so i'm right behind this motion thank
you for bringing it up thank you council
partner councillor autumn
um thank you chairman i mean i can't
believe anybody would not vote for this
motion um
as councillor pasmore said we have seen
some heartbreaking
examples of children
old people coping
with trying to
disappear from what was happening
as far as what we as a council can do
i'd like to ask the question
that all i hope the assumption will be
that the council will not
take back the 25
discount for somebody who was a single
person
if they are then taking somebody into
their home to live there as a refugee
um i'd like to arthur to respond to that
thank you chairman i we haven't formally
made that decision yet but i fully
anticipate based upon the mood of the
the roman from what i've heard from the
councillors over the recent weeks that
that's exactly what we would do so
anybody with a single person discount
that takes somebody into their home that
they would retain that single person
discount unaffected yet that's my
assumption
i
asked then that we actually get formal
notification that that is that the
council will do that in case we are
asked by people in the community thank
you
thank you councillorton
councilmellon
yeah thank you chair um
i'm very grateful um for councillor
morley bringing this
bringing this motion forward and um
you know watching the news is is is a
tough thing at the moment as we all know
it's just heartbreaking to see what's
going on there
i think we all understand the limits of
of what can be done um militarily
you know if nato was ever to come into
kind of direct conflict with russia it
would be
a nightmare and we have to hold back
from that but i understand that you know
our government is doing all it can
in terms of supplying
the ukrainians with what they need to
fight
back um you know this this guy putin is
we're now kind of seeing him for what he
really is
uh he has he's kind of gaslit the whole
country he's brainwashed them i really
don't think the russians really want to
fight the ukrainians but they've they've
been told a whole pack of lies and and
it's based on that
but what i see in our communities is
it's this kind of visceral reaction that
we want to help we want we want to do
something
and you know we've seen collection
points where people have gathered
together all sorts of stuff to send over
there and people going over to eastern
europe in vans and lorries
and that may be helpful um i'm
encouraging people to give money to the
you know
the the deck appeal and perhaps more
importantly
and lots of people are registering to to
host refugees you know we've done that
uh we're lucky enough to have a spare
room that we we hope we can get some
people into
and i'm really glad that the government
has put this scheme in place and they
haven't put a limit on it so that we
could get a really good number over here
i wish it was a little bit more generous
in terms of
a mechanism to bring these people over
so they don't have to you know find
their own flight money or or sponsor to
pay it if there's people that you know
that need help in and poland seems to be
full
let's get them over here let's get them
into people's homes we want to help
we want to support our communities in
helping
and i'm grateful that this motion has
come forward and i'll be waiting for it
thank you chair thank you councilman
council of war boys
yes thank you chair um
i'm in favor and glad to see that this
motion has come forward
my only concern is that the language of
the motion isn't strong enough
this is more than unprovoked
it is illegal it is criminal
um
russia the behavior of the russian
troops that's been documented so far in
the ukraine
uh open libel to
war crimes
and persecution
as war criminals
um
so i feel unprovoked doesn't quite
say enough for me
and perhaps counsel molly would consider
strengthening
that
language um
it has been described as genocidal in
the guardian today
it was a case of a survivor
from the second world war a 96 year old
man who survived belson buccan world
nazi
work camps
and in fact three years
in the soviet army after being
um
released
he was killed in a rocket attack today
a russian rocket attack on civilian
areas
this is it is appalling
um and i think
the language could be strengthened a
little to recognize this thank you
hello boys
um does anyone else wish to speak
okay um well i mean i do i do
uh concur with the general tenet of the
discussion
that has gone on this evening i mean
this is a
a cowardly
commercially
horrible thing to for for putin and his
gang
to visit upon the ukrainians and i'm
sure that
we all wish them the best and we will do
everything we can to support them and
i'm very pleased to say the government
is really
leading on that um
so
with that i'll ask councillor molly if
you would like to add anything further
okay in that case we shall move to the
electronic vote please
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors would like to
place their votes thank you
cancer string are you having problems
thank you
chair that is 29 votes for that is
unanimous
thank you all very much that is carried
[Applause]
so we'll now move to
the third motion for this evening that
is
item 15c
to consider the motion or notice
received from counselor stringer
council stringer would you like to move
your motion
thank you chair uh delighted to move the
motion uh that this council notes our
continued support for neighbourhood
plans
as the expression of communities
intentions and aspirations
for development
uh i'll stray away from the wording
therefore i mean i had the pleasure of
being the
representing the first village that got
a neighbour made a neighbourhood plan
in mid suffolk district
and that was that was off the back of
hundreds of hours of voluntary work not
by me i i left the document well alone i
felt it was in a way the people's
document i get enough chance to
interfere with development control and i
thought this was the opportunity for the
uh the good people of middlestrom to
come and have their say as to what they
wanted
and they did we had some fantastic
consultations
lots of people putting sticky dots on
maps where they did want it where they
didn't want it
and the reasons why
even even quite a few surprises for us
that had to try and enact this plan
which which is great
which means it's also very important to
the community as a document
uh
and government
often we accuse them of not listening
but government have listened but in this
instance because it's part of the
legislative framework of our development
plan
a made neighborhood plan in the eyes of
the government at the moment
is that if that's bolted on to the
national planning policy framework that
is a made development plan for any given
area
quite right too because it's been worked
with the people
on behalf of the people and it aligns
with with government policy
as it should also align with with our
major policies here
at the district
so i think
we
also i think what we have struggled with
uh
over the years has been
how
frustrating changes in legislation has
have slowed up some of the plans
and and also it's been difficult to get
enough resource in for everyone's needs
we have basically a resource of one
officer here uh
at the moment it's now been brought up
to two which is great uh but that's an
awful lot of workload at times bearing
in mind we also would like as many
parishes as possible to have made
neighborhood plans we've now got the
original batch of plans now coming up to
five years some of them that will also
need reviewing so the workload of that
in in the upcoming years it is probably
going to be
greater
so
quite pleased to move the motion
and i hope we can be as unanimous about
this motion as we was the previous one
thank you thank you councillor uh can i
have a second there please
uh councillor miller
thank you chair um
yeah this um this motion um
focuses particularly on on the needs of
um the core villages in our
emerging joint local plan
um
i'm sure you know all of them 14 core
villages i wouldn't ask you to name them
right now um
but those those have become kind of key
places in terms of the development of
the district because those are the
places where
lots of our planning applications are
going to
and what's become clear over the last
little while
that is that um
these neighborhood plans where they're
made are very very important legally
particularly as
the the full adoption of the joint local
plan has sort of receded a little bit
further into the distance
and particularly the part two of that
plan
um
now we know lots of work has gone into
these these neighborhood plans uh in the
villages that have done them
and they've become more important
legally and i think it's just really
important at this moment
to kind of restate to reiterate the fact
that this council supports neighborhood
plans
um
i've talked to one or two clerks who
have become a little bit cynical about
them
um to be fair and we're talking about
not just people in small villages but
some of our larger villages you've got
clerks you say well the process is just
so long
that we don't you know see the end of it
and i spoke to another clerk who said
that he felt the only purpose of an of a
neighbourhood plan was to get that extra
10 percent of the sill
and we know there's a bigger purpose
there it really does guide the
development
but we need to be certain that all that
work that's gone into a neighborhood
plan is is is something that we respect
as a council that we don't seek to
undermine it we don't seek to overturn
it we don't seek to allow
applications which go against what a
neighborhood plan has intended
so i think it's really important uh that
we restate that right now
um
and particularly focus on these core
villages um ones which perhaps didn't
want to do a neighbour plan a few years
ago
perhaps the parish council
you know the makeup of it has changed
new a new clerk a new chairman uh and
and these people could be talked to and
and perhaps persuaded that it's a good
idea to do it now um so i think that's
what we're aiming for
and i hope that everyone will support
this motion thank you chair thank you
councillor merlin um we are going to now
move to debate uh councillors will have
three minutes and we'll be able to speak
once and um this will be time so uh
councillor byrne i see you um thank you
uh
thank you chair um
[Music]
it's going to eat into my three minutes
unfortunately but i didn't recognize
quite a lot of what councilmemen was
saying as forming part of this motion
supporting neighborhood plans after
they've been made is not a part of it
that i can see
and overturning
overturning planning
planning recommendations on this on the
strength of
uh
neighborhood plans uh not not being uh
no sorry i've got that mixed mixed up
the wrong way around but um i think you
know what i mean i i don't recognize a
lot of what you were saying i'm afraid
counselor mellon
because first of all let me declare that
i strongly support i mean i'm a big
supporter of
the neighborhood planning concept
to give an element of control to
communities over development in their
areas as introduced
in the as part of the localism act 2011
was a very good thing
it also gave them an opportunity to
protect components of their environment
that they most value
now then that was 11 years ago so how
much of a good thing has it been
there are some 120 parishes in
mid-suffolk and to date we have only
15 adopted neighborhood plans and
another 13 at various stages of
preparation
now together that's about 23 percent of
our parishes
now given that it takes a long time to
create a neighborhood plan and there's
no no getting away from that fact it is
a lengthy process and the statutory uh
requirements um
mean that it has to be so
it takes at least two years for a
relatively straightforward one
would we regard that figure as an
acceptable take-up over the past decade
do the parishes need more encouragement
and support to embark on the
neighborhood plan journey
the members who brought this motion to
council obviously think so
but we do need to look at closely at
what added value it will bring to the
table
let me first make a distinction between
those two words encouragement and
support
do our parishes need encouragement oh
most certainly they do as council mellon
pointed out
but that's something all of us as ward
members should have been giving them
ever since the localism act was
introduced and it is our responsibility
to sell the idea to our parish councils
do they need support most certainly
but for those parishes that have
recognized the benefits and showed
interest and effort
support has been made available
available to them
in abundance
financial and otherwise from various
sources
we have certain statutory statutory
obligations to support the creation of a
neighborhood plan we designate the area
we administer the consultation when the
draft plan is submitted and collate the
results we organize the examination we
arranged with the parish council to
carry out the examiner's recommendations
and we organized the referendum we also
have an obligation throughout the
process to give advice on request
we mustn't forget that the underlying
principle of a neighborhood plan is that
it is community-led
it is not intended to be local planning
authority led
encouragement yes by all means but more
support than we already give plus that
already available from a multitude of
sources
no i don't think that's necessary
and so far as encouragement goes on top
of what what we as ward members should
be giving all the time as a matter of
course
we've only recently approved the funding
uh to create a post that will do exactly
that reaching out to our communities
selling them the idea and pointing them
in the right direction we should
certainly be showing them the benefits
of drinking the water but actually
drinking it is largely up to them
although i entirely support the central
sentiment behind the motion i don't
believe it will achieve more than is
already
available
uh and or soon will be and so therefore
i don't think i can support it
thank you kathleen byrne councillor
mansell
thank you chair
as a as a member with two large core
villages in my ward
uh one of whom has had their uh had
their
neighborhood plan which spent which was
after a lot of community work and
engagement um went to cabinet in october
2020
um and it was said that they were going
to have to deal with the modifications
set out in the independent examiner's
report
and they and that particular community
asked mid-suffolk officers to help them
with those modifications that is nearly
18 months ago
and clearly we need more resources
there we have
councillor byrne saying oh it takes
about two years well this one's been 18
months stuck at one stage and it's stuck
at one stage
partly because mid-suffolk doesn't have
sufficient resources to move it on
the other core village that is part of
my ward
is also desperate to have a neighborhood
plan and gets frustrated at every step
of the way so i am fully
in support of this motion
we clearly need to have more resources
going towards neighborhood plans so that
these uh core villages these bigger
communities they are complicated they
are
very
difficult to deal with
and and we clearly need to to be
allocating resources so that they can
get their neighborhood plan on the table
and made so that it becomes part of our
planning policy i am fully in support of
this motion we need to help these
villages it's it's it's so complicated
for lay people to get their heads around
we need to offer them more support thank
you
thank you councilman
councillor guthrie
thank you very much indeed i was very
pleased to hear that councillor stringer
had the first neighborhood plan up and i
do believe you were the first to have to
amend it for various reasons
mid-suffolk has been a strong supporter
of the importance and value of
neighbourhood plans since their original
introduction as part of the localism act
that passion for neighborhood plans is
as strong today as it was then
as you will be aware we receive funding
from government to support neighborhood
planning and allocate those resources to
our own accordingly and to make sure we
are all proactively supporting
each community in the right way
throughout the development adoption and
implementation of their neighbourhood
plan
this is a tailored approach to suit the
nature of the community bringing forward
their plan and we have a memorandum of
understanding in place so that the
communities
know which elements
the mid-suffolk district council will
deliver and which areas are the
responsibility of the community
as we know a huge amount of voluntary
work and effort goes into these plans by
our residents and communities
the adoption of the plan is not the end
of the story
though and we do have to interpret each
neighborhood plan for each relevant
application against our own
local planning our own local policy
position and the national planning
policy framework
as we know this isn't always clear-cut
and will result in challenges such we're
currently seeing at thurston
it wouldn't be appropriate to expand
further on that situation here tonight
but please be assured that mid-suffolk
is totally committed to the neighborhood
planning and therefore i see no need for
this motion thank you
thank you councillor guthrie councillor
otton
thank you chairman um i'm afraid i am
going to mention the um elephant in the
room
and that is the judicial review
on thurston
application
and
the comments by the judge
on how this council
took into account thurson's neighborhood
plan
i councillor richardson
former councillor here wendy turner have
sat in thurston parish council meetings
where they have felt that their
neighborhood plan was not
taken into account
what this motion is putting forward
is for this council to reiterate
its commitment to neighborhood plans
and to be able to say to those
parishes now
we do take your neighborhood plan
seriously we want to support you and it
will be part of the process
and i really think
this would be a really good pr exercise
to go out to the rest of those parishes
who now may feeling somewhat cynical
about the council's attitude to
neighbourhood plans and i would urge
councillors to support the motion thank
you
thank you councillor councillor
amarossan
thank you chair
um i'd just like to point out what might
be an apparent uh contradiction made
uh by councillor byrne earlier in his
statement which was that he acknowledged
that
um
there had been a low take-up
of uh local neighborhood plans
and but also that uh we needed to
improve our encouragement
of
of the take-up of neighbourhood plans
and therefore if if we're doing both if
we're doing that thing then we expect
that there's going to be more take-up
which would require
more resources
to
to deal with those
it appears we're already struggling with
uh with the current uh workload
uh on on those so
i'm confused by the uh
that paradox
made by
councillor burn sorry
thanks
thank you uh cafe geek
thank you chair um
in common with councillor mansell i'm
the other councillor for two core
villages without adopted neighbourhood
plans uh just to look at um one of them
we've been expecting the wool pit
neighborhood plan to appear any minute
now for six months we've continually
been told that it's imminent since as
far back as last summer the parish
council has offered to take it back in
house to pay a consultant to get it done
to finish it off but we keep being told
there's no point it's nearly there just
dust in the eyes crossing the tees
you'll have it you'll have it in a
couple of weeks in a couple of weeks in
a couple of weeks
now the officer working on it is
completely fantastic i cannot fault the
officer working on it but clearly
the system is very very under-resourced
i'm now beginning to hear conspiracy
theories among my residents it might not
be in mid-suffolk district council's
interest to get that neighborhood plan
finished i hear people saying that by
the time we get to our 25 of sill the
village will already have doubled in
size there won't be any building left to
generate that cell
i try to put them straight but sometimes
it's very hard to disagree with them so
i will be supporting this motion
thank you councillor councillor field
thank you
i think i know of four
core villages in in the ipswich fringe
as a county council i used to represent
them all but it's now obviously that's
no longer true but james caston supports
branford
tim passmore's clayton and byram
and i still look after great blakenham
all of which produced
detailed village design statements and
plans
the the last time i heard their views it
was
well we're not going to bother with an
able plan it's a shed load of work
and nobody will take any notice
so we don't do it
i'm sure we probably all agree that
neighborhood plans are pretty vital and
we do need to get villages to do the
work
it seems to me that this uh proposal
this motion has within it
some of the elements you clearly need
one of them is an authoritative voice to
say a neighborhood plan is part of the
development plan
the work is worth doing it will have an
effect
people will take notice and this sort of
includes that
the final paragraph allocate have
advocate
advocates get it right the
allocation of resources appropriate to
meet the objectives we have
that clearly is another issue in my view
that these parishes have they don't feel
there's a readily available resource
that they can lean on to help guide them
to produce a competent plan
so i certainly will be supporting this
motion
thank you councillor councillor
humphreys
mr chair thank you
i don't really understand the emotion
i've read through it a few times and i'm
like okay which bit are you trying to
make so um there's a key part
development plan neighborhood plans
helps guide that's that's a statement
and then we go on to in particular
working together with parish council
community groups is council actively
promote and encourage the process of
developing a neighbourhood plan i've
just been on our website it does exactly
that in many areas and gives them the
help and guidance that they actually
require and actually everybody in this
room has a role to play in that you're
all ward members go out and promote it
so there's the first point we don't need
a policy we don't need a statement for
that go and do your job if you think
it's that important go and promote it
and assist them and guide them and
signpost them to the people that help
because councillor burns absolutely
right this comes down to us
not the officers us that's where it
starts i don't need you to come along
and we need to we need to make a
statement this should be doing it anyway
i don't get it i don't get the reason
why he puts motion in honestly i don't
see it the resources are there the
advice is there the signpost is there
and you've all got a job all of us go
out and do your job thank you
thank you uh councillor welland
thank you chair um
i have to i have to respond to that
i
before i was a district councillor i
started the neighborhood plan for stow
upland
um
so i did my job even though i wasn't the
district councillor and i've been still
being doing my job in other in other
parishes as well
as people were claiming first i believe
i was the first district councillor to
have their main neighborhood plan given
little weight in the planning decision
allowing 60 homes
on an area of land that was not
allocated in the neighborhood plan
so
still upland and others other parishes
have lost faith in the council's ability
to give proper consideration to
neighbourhood planned policies when
making decisions on planning
applications
stowe upland parish council that
their plan was given little weight
despite being the most recent planning
guidance document and therefore the most
relevant development plan document
as a result they and other parishes have
decided not to update their plans or in
many cases to to produce an initial
neighbourhood plan
it's therefore essential that there are
resources made available to promote
neighborhood plans
and encourage councils to start the
process
and in the case of neighbor
neighbourhood plans which are already or
will soon be in need of updating
to provide the resources to review them
there's going to be a lot of work in
updating helping updating and reviewing
so we need the extra staff i'll be
voting for the motion and i hope that
there will be sufficient resources made
available
not just
for the core villages to produce their
first plans but also to review existing
plans in need of updating thank you
thank you councillor welcome counselor
carter
oh
thank you
um i've previously been involved in
councils who have
honestly felt
district council to be
almost competitive against them getting
the plan that's were feeling they fell
it seemed to be every time they tried to
dot an eye across the tee there was
something else to come back with
and the feeling it was oh we're not
going to do it because we want to put
this planning event and we want to
protect this area but they're going to
put houses there that's why we're
holding it back
i've talked to other parish clerks
and
the same thing goes but
they say
oh we've been through south meetings
it's all they're not going to help what
what's the point of going for it it's
it's wonderful and paid it's going to
cost us a lot of money and there's not
gonna be listen to
they don't see any help they don't see
any commitment from us here
it's wonderful yes
do our jobs go out there sell it
but what are we setting if we are saying
something that i have no faith in
what have we said what have we acted on
to say that we are here to help you
we are going to stick by what we say we
are going to actually commit to what we
are assisting you to do
and you are going to see a benefit
if it's only going to cost them in the
long run
and if it's going to be thrown back in
their faces
and
they see no commitment from here
why is there going to be an uptake
so i'd fully support this motion if
we're actually saying
yes
we have are helping you
yes we are supporting you and yes we
stick by our word
thank you
thank you councillor councillor fleming
yes thank you thank you chairman um i
just thought i
need to say something because
i can't support this motion as it's
currently worded but i think everyone
who knows me
knows that i am an ardent supporter of
effective neighborhood planning
and i just like to say something about
what that conundrum
means
i don't believe that the
problems with neighborhood planning that
have been alluded to here relate to
lack of resources i believe it's lack of
material effect that neighborhood plans
can actually have and that's what i'm
hearing
people
i've have
four neighborhood plans going on in my
division and all the parishes concerned
have received excellent support from
mid-suffolk
so um
and add to that
mid-suffolk is hiring and or looking to
hire additional planners
it's not easy to find planners we are
doing our best they can't just be
magicked up with the wave of a wand
i believe that
we need to work harder on making sure
that the neighborhood neighborhood plans
fit with the joint local plan as it
develops and the planning committees and
and officers have the tools necessary to
really take notice of
and take into account neighborhood
concerns and neighborhood plans that's
the part that needs work it's not
what's what is in the motion before us
today this motion does not address
the problems in neighborhood planning
that have been raised this evening thank
you
thank you councillor flaming
council war boys
thank you chair um
yes i
there's no arguing with the fact i think
that mitch suffolk district council
taken nationally is
well ahead of the game with regards to
neighbourhood plans it's doing well
nationally but you know 12
of our parishes and neighborhood plans
that's not really a pass mark is it
we have
the structure in place to support our
communities this motion is just about
revisiting that structure and
reinvigorate it so we can get
the enthusiasm
amongst our parish councils for
neighborhood plans
um
i represent gizligan ward
none of my villagers uh parish councils
have neighborhood plans in place they're
small price councils for the last two
years i've consistently brought up the
need for neighborhood planning and how
important it is
in decision making
and how significant it is
there is changes to the planning
uh regulations coming down
the road the white papers i have seen
about it there is going to be an
assumption that every
significant parish
has a neighborhood plan in place
uh we can't underestimate the amount of
work done by parishes
and prepare the neighborhood plans
this
this motion is an opportunity to just
revisit
the structure
reinvigorate it and
try to bring forward those parishes that
are reluctant to get involved in it
thank you so i'm going to support the
motion
thank you council of war boys
councillor you've already had your turn
i'm afraid
um so even though one of us councillor
flatman
i have one core village stradbro
i have four
small villages i have one going to the
vote on saturday and i have one tiny
village
hamlet
with
probably 50 residents and they don't
even have a parish council however all
my other villagers either have a
neighbourhood plan or as i say the last
one is going for theirs on saturday one
of those villages have 90 residents 90.
do you know what this is all about this
is about leading the horse to the water
you cannot make them drink if you've got
villagers that want to do a neighborhood
plan they certainly will and as
councillor stringer said the rooms are
full of stickers what they want it's not
all about planning it's about green
spaces
how many school places what the
villagers actually want and i'm sorry
it's all about the community if they
want it they'll get it and if stradbroke
were here laxfield were here and wilby
were here they would say our offices
were outstanding all the way through
one little problem i had lex field
emailed me
emailed me to say what's happened we
haven't heard anything so i give our
officer a call what's going on we sent
them an email three months ago they just
need to do one little thing they hadn't
looked at the email
come on it's up to the individual
villages
thank you councillor flatman uh i think
that basically brings us to the end of
the debate um so
uh councillor stringer do you wish to
add anything
oh yes i would no i thought
i have to say i'm actually quite shocked
by some of the responses
the clue to the motion
is in the first sentence continued
support
if we wanted to draft something that was
overtly political and nasty we could
have done it and we didn't
i think
now is a perfect time for this authority
to reassert that we support you if
you're going to put those hundreds of
hours of voluntary work into producing
or updating a neighborhood plan we will
stand by you and make sure you get that
resource and frankly it's a bit
difficult taking lectures
from district councils that will never
have a neighborhood plan because they
have something called a area action plan
which was 100 funded by this council and
resourced by this council for staff
hours
we some of us represent people that have
put hundreds and hundreds of hours in
because they believe
that this council will listen to them
this motion is the perfect example and
the perfect time to show that we will
listen
and some of the tone i've really not
liked the barber tone about mendelssohn
decided to they had to change their
naval ban no they didn't it was made in
2017 it will be ruled potentially out of
date by the government in five years
so for them to do a review of it it's
actually quite timely
and really good management thank you
we are getting resource from the
district council in doing this but like
everything else within planning policy
we are in a queue and often the
responses are nowhere near as
timely as we would wish now we're not
going to apportion blame to that all we
want is that reassertion from you
mid-suffolk district council that if we
put in those hours which we have done if
we consult which we have done that you
will stand by us and you will quote
continue to stand by us
this is your opportunity to back that
continued support
i frankly didn't think this would be a
huge issue as a motion
but clearly it is
clearly some members on that other side
have severe doubts
about neighborhood plans their validity
etc etc and somehow that if you haven't
got a neighborhood plan
in your area and you have a key service
center you're not doing your job as a
district councillor i completely refute
that completely 100
because
it is up to those individuals and
sometimes it's an issue of
credibility so those existing plans i
can take you to a parish council that
says absolutely not worth doing a
neighborhood plan look at what's
happened elsewhere and how easily the
made ones have been dismissed so never
ever allude to that i will be proud to
support this motion because i will as an
elected district councillor continue to
support my neighborhood plans
and i will continue to support all of
the neighborhood plans of all the
elected members of this council i beg
you to do the same thank you chief
concludes the debate
and i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please thank you
chair that vote is now showing in blue
for councillors to cast their vote
cancer stringer do you want to cast your
vote i better vote for since i proposed
it
and councillor mellon
okay
chair that is
votes 15 4
13 against and one abstention so that is
carried
then move to the last motion for
consideration this evening
um
as you're well aware counselor eben is
not with us this evening so i'm going to
ask councillor mellon to move this
particular motion council mellon
yeah yes thank you chair um
i won't take too long with with this um
so we have a very simple motion here um
and i'm very pleased to on behalf of
council rebound propose this motion on
adopting the
net zero carbon toolkit
which has been adopted by three
district which has been developed by
three district councils very similar to
ours
uh with a grant from the local
government association's housing
advisors program and we hear a lot of
talk about uh net zero carbon
and this council declared a climate
emergency nearly three years ago
there was a member group looking
initiatives and and we have a plan in
place as a result of that
um
we're also we'll be very aware now of
the rising
uh prices of energy and the kind of
crisis
of living costs
and actually getting to net zero carbon
in housing will mean we can be more in
control of this reducing energy costs in
the home
and being able to have a positive impact
on on fuel poverty
but here we have an initiative which
embodies much of this and is very
straightforward for us to support
what brought this home to me was a
conversation with with a developer um
after a planning meeting
he came to me after a plan meeting said
you guys keep talking about sustainable
building techniques
what do you mean by that
and
i do see too many of our developments
which are using the very very
traditional ways of building when they
could be looking at much more modern and
more sustainable things
so um just from the toolkit itself
this thing drawing together latest
guidance and best practice the net zero
carbon toolkit is a practical easy to
follow guide to help plan a net zero
housing project
and it's for builders it's for
architects self-builders and also for
homeowners just wanting to retrofit or
extend their property and it gives them
the kind of guidance and advice they
would need
and implementing the measures laid out
in this toolkit would help reduce the
carbon footprint of new and existing
buildings
the key point in this motion is this
although this is a guide
and we're not making in any sense it to
be mandatory we want our office to be
promoting this
they can promote it right through the
planning process
um at pre-application meetings in
discussions um between builders and
developers
right through the process including the
building rigs team this is the kind of
key point that we want to make here we
can't make this mandatory that we know
the law won't allow that at the moment
there's a frustration really that the
levels of building
standards are not what they really need
to be
and they're moving in the right
direction but this guide if we promoted
it if we pushed it to people
in the planning process
uh would be something that would help
them it would guide them
uh it would it would lead them in the
right direction and could make some real
impacts
in reducing um uh reducing the amount of
carbon emitted by our homes the ones
we've built already and the ones we're
going to build in the future so i
commend this uh this motion to the to
the council thank you chad
thank you councilman uh could i have a
second to please
counselor field
do you wish to speak now
wait
okay
right we will now move to debate
catholic
i'd like to make a point of information
if i'm a chair
thank you
this is this is actually very timely
because
we held our suffolk public sector
leaders
planning meeting on friday
at which
as chair of spsl
i approved this document for use across
the whole of suffolk councils
so
clearly
you did you didn't know about that
and
to be fair most on this side didn't know
either but
the um there was a a bit of a
discrepancy in the process that was
followed
but
the whole of the suffolk public sector
leaders group on friday authorized me to
sign off this document and distribute it
so with your permission i'd like to read
you the forward that i've i've placed in
that document
suffolk's local authorities have a
shared and collective ambition to work
towards the aspiration of a carbon
neutral suffolk by 2030
and a key theme of our climate emergency
plan is the delivery of sustainable
homes both new housing and through the
retrofit of existing homes
achieving such an aspiration is no small
task
nor is it one that any single person or
organization can achieve alone
it requires everyone to come together to
work collectively to share in their
experiences and to build on their
successes along the way
as local planning authorities we are
dedicated to supporting individuals
businesses and communities on this
pathway to net zero
this is why we are publishing this net
zero carbon toolkit
a practical and easy to navigate guide
on how to plan your net zero housing
project that should be considered in
conjunction with your local authorities
planning policies and building
regulations
whether you are a small or medium-sized
house builder an architect a
self-builder
or a consultant advising clients
this toolkit will help you explaining
how net zero can be delivered through
construction
this document has been adopted across
the entire suffolk system
i will be supporting it
thank you council morning councillor
so just question one little word in that
forward which was great
you said should
and
as we're all in agreement should we make
that [ __ ]
a must
that is not what has been signed off by
suffolk public sector leaders group
council fleming
yes thank you um i just wanted to um
speak a little bit about this version um
as the
cabinet member for environment
and building i just
would like to make a couple of points
um i have even though it's come at
fairly short notice i've
read the toolkit
um summary not all the entire document
and it i can see that it contains some
very excellent features and some new
ideas that i really hope we can bring
into the planning system
some things which maybe we aren't doing
now as much as we um should be and i
particularly welcome the consistent
approach to sustainable design across
the county and
hopefully across the country
i do note
within the document actually it's on
page two
with reference to how the lga envisions
individual local authority should use
the toolkit
the
lga advisory states please feel free to
adopt this toolkit as you wish to make
it specific to your local authority your
geography or circumstances
and this is what i hope we will be able
to do going forward
i believe that um
there's much work to be done to
familiarize ourselves with its content
and i hope that meetings with the
other environment portfolio holders in
suffolk and
building regulations
offices and
other colleagues may
bring out some of the things within this
toolkit that are particularly important
to mid suffolk
and
and emphasize those so that our planning
guidance to developers isn't just here's
the toolkit this is what we expect you
to do
we've got some work to do to to look at
the content here and say this is
particularly what we expect you to do in
mid-suffolk these are the parts of it
that are really important
because there may be areas that we wish
to emphasize more
and there may be areas that maybe we
wish to play down so on that note i'm
happy to support the motion
but i do think there's some more work to
be done before we actually bring it to
the attention of developers and and
implement it thank you
thank you councillor fleming
kathleen
thank you
um
all i want to do is ask uh councillor
fleming whether she said the word adopt
or adapt
at the beginning of
i think she said
no i i said adapt did you good
okay
would anyone else wish to speak on this
motion
okay in which case let us um
i beg your pardon you you're right to
speak please
thank you i hope you weren't trying to
shortchange me
but i will be brief as i'm sure at this
time of night everybody will be rather
pleased about
um
i i find
this toolkit it seems to me to be really
useful
i know as a householder and i'm sure as
a small builder it's rather difficult to
decide it's actually what you should be
doing for for a
move towards zero carbon
there's a lot of work there clearly
large developers may well have
specialist departments that can do that
sort of thing
we don't see a lot of evidence of that i
must say planning committees but
nevertheless they have the resource but
this provides a common basis which is as
has been said has been produced by a set
of district councils using government
funding and is clearly competent and
something we should
adopt in my view
the important bit perhaps is the last
sentence of the
last paragraph of the motion which says
we will promote the
zero carbon toolkit to applicants at all
stages for planning and building control
application process it does say we'll
promote it it doesn't say real
issue some terrible punishment if they
don't obey but but it is good guidance
it is something that must help us
forward as a district council and
suffolk forward as
public leaders are pushing
so i'm pleased to see we all seem to be
singing from
something close to the same hymn sheet
and i will just uh advocate that you
support this motion
thank you thank you castlefield
counselor melon good
yeah thank you chair um just to sum up
briefly um i'm very grateful for um
councillor morley sharing her
a very
very right forward to the um to the
guide
and she introduced it far better than i
did
so i'm grateful that appears to be a lot
of support for this idea and i hope it
will be really useful
and i i encourage everyone to support it
thank you
we will now move to the electronic vote
please
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if councillors can cast their
vote
chair that is 28 votes for that is
unanimous
um i'd just like to uh thank each and
every one of you for what has been quite
an
interesting set of debates during the
course of this evening i think
it's my conclusion that there's more
that unites us than divides us
particularly when it comes to the
concerns of our residents
whom we put
you know first and foremost and i'm sure
that um
you know the some of the concerns that
have been raised will be addressed by
officers
uh as a matter of priority going forward
so i'd like to thank you
and
to remind you that the next meeting of
this council will be on thursday the
26th of may
at 5 30 pm and i look forward to seeing
you all there
i wish you all a very good night
you